- On this episode, I talk about
extroverted personalities,
Instagram versus Twitter,
and why you would ever
hire someone or outsource.
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(intro music)
'Sup everyone, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 56
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Before I get into the show,
I wanna talk about my manic obsession
that I was just talking
the team with right now
of my Instagram game in 2015.
So, if you're not
following me on the Insta,
I need you to do that immediately
or it'll be the single
biggest regret of your 2015.
- [Voiceover] Roommate Harmony asks,
"Hey Gary, do you think
it's necessary to have
an outgoing personality to
be a successful entrepreneur?"
- Roommate Harmony, this
is a tremendous question.
I think there's never been less important
to be extroverted to be a
successful entrepreneur.
Oh, I don't know.
Just look at every successful entrepreneur
that everybody talks about.
Like Zucks and Ev
Williams and Kevin Systrom
and David Karp.
You know, Facebook, Twitter,
Tumblr, and Instagram.
I mean, Ben Silbermann, Pinterest.
I mean...
It's actually the glory days
of the introvert entrepreneur.
Because of technology, because
of sitting behind the screen,
because it doesn't all
happen face to face anymore,
it's never been a better time to do that.
And that's, not by the
way, always been the way.
There's way to win at, you know,
it's about betting on strengths.
I do things based on my strengths.
I'm an entrepreneur that is extroverted
and I surround myself with people
and I do that kind of stuff.
I put myself out there.
Introverted entrepreneurs
need to not fake the funk.
Like, it'd be stupid for
me to sit behind a computer
all day, every day
and then that was just the way I rolled.
Mistake, leaving the magic on the table.
Equally, someone who is awkward
and is like, yeah my
startup is, thank you.
Yeah, my startup is really,
like that guy or gal is
probably not the kind of person
that wants to kind of
bet on their personality
and they need to sit down all day
and focus and so I think
it's betting on strengths.
- [Voiceover] Daniel
asks, "Numbers of monthly
active users aside, do you think Instagram
is actually a larger social
network than Twitter?"
- Daniel, I think that
Instagram and Twitter
are tremendously different.
I think Twitter is kind of the town hall,
the cocktail party of our society.
When things happen in the world,
you know, that's where we're going.
You know, unfortunate
hostage situation in Sydney,
I'm not running to Insta
to see the pictures.
I'm running to Twitter
for the conversation.
On the flip side, I do not
believe there's a social network
in the world that exists right now
that has more the end
attention of the consumer
than Instagram.
Meaning we're looking at those
pictures pretty carefully.
In this world, by comparison,
you know, this episode's gonna
tie nice together because,
nicely, because I know the other questions
and I know my push for Insta.
I think it's about attention on the Gram
and I think that's where
it's really winning.
I think people are
really consuming content
and paying attention.
One of the reasons that
Twitter is evolving is,
you know, I used to be able
to send a tweet six years ago
and even though with substantially less
of an audience of reach, I had more action
because the attention was more serious.
Now the fire hose has gotten so intense
so those are the variables.
From a net-net game of attention,
I think it's pretty close
but Instagram is clearly
going in the right direction.
They just both act
differently, that's all.
- [Voiceover] Lisa wants to know,
"What actor would you want
to play you in a movie
about your life?"
- Lisa, when the movie of my life is made,
which I'm pretty substantially
betting on it happening,
you know, what I'm
looking for in 25 years,
'cause I'm a slower grinder, right.
Like, don't get confused VaynerNation.
99% of the world has no
idea who I am, minimumly.
But I'm a grinder and I
feel good about where I sit
in the "is this worthy of a movie" lexicon
in 25-30 years from now.
So I don't know who I want to play me
because obviously there'll
be different versions
but whoever is the most attractive
would be the direction I'd be looking for.
- [Voiceover] Todd asks,
"I notice that you post
the same things multiple times.
Please explain why this
is a calculated move
and not obnoxious."
- Todd, everything I do is calculated.
And so, the answer's yes, it's calculated
and the reason I'm posting
multiple times a day
and I think you're referring
to clearly, Twitter,
is the before mentioned answer
in the Instagram question
couple questions ago which
is Twitter has gotten noisy.
I've looked at data and intuition,
looked inside myself,
and decided that it's okay
for me to do it multiple times
'cause the speed is happening.
The hardcore fans who will accept that
it's okay, I've seen that
and just so many, call it 90% of people
that want to consume my
content, I mean still
somethings that I'm on the 19th time on
like the Twitter mistake on the deck,
you know, I put out today
and people are like "oh"
and like, you know,
there's just so much noise
that I feel the market has changed
and I think it's appropriate
almost like a scrolling bar
at the bottom of ESPN, right?
If you think about that,
that's looping the same stuff
and it doesn't bother me.
I can choose to look at the bottom or not
and weirdly and I'm
sure all of you do this,
sometimes you just look
again and again and again.
It's kind of wild that way.
I think that Twitter's
fire hose now replicates
the bottom ticker of CNBC and ESPN
and I think it's the right execution
to put out your stuff at different times,
different time zones.
I wanna hit my European and Asian,
and Non US family, what's up, Non US?
I wanna hit my West Coast peeps, you know?
You gotta play it differently
and that's just the way it is
and I think it's appropriate
in a December 16, 2014 world
to put out the same content
multiple times on the Twitter.
I like calling it on the Twitter.
In a world where in
December 16th, you know,
2008, I felt differently.
I changed my mind consistently
which is why I think I win.
And honestly, which is why I think
I'm worth the attention that
you're applying to this show
and why I think this format works
because the game is
changing quickly and often
and if you're not adjusting,
you're gonna lose.
The '85 Bears won on a system
that doesn't work in today's NFL.
Heck, heck, the 2000, who
won last year, the Seahawks.
The Seahawks aren't even able
to execute the same game plan
as last year in the NFL
because of the way the officials call
pass interference and
things of that nature
and so you just gotta keep evolving
and if you don't, you lose.
And that's the evolution of my game.
So advice that I gave in
jab, jab, jab, right hook
would have looked differently
today about Twitter
because between the time I wrote it
and this minute, the game has changed.
- So Gary Vee, this is what I wanna know.
Because you have this 500 person agency,
I want you to explain why
people should use a digital agency?
- For looks.
- What's the circumstances?
When not to use it, when to use it?
How do you optimize it?
Well basically, give us the gist.
Why use an agency?
Why not cultivate all this talent inside
and control it, own it,
et cetera, et cetera.
Thank you, Gary.
- Thank you, Guy.
Guy K, one of the real
thought leaders in this space.
He's too humble to do it
but I know he has a new book out
and I wanna give love to people
so DRock, Staphon, take
over the page here.
Give him a little shout out.
Let's link it up below.
One of the few authors I feel
comfortable enough in saying,
check out what they're doing so
VaynerNation, check out what Guy's doing.
It's a great question, Guy.
As a matter of fact,
the answer's even better
'cause I'm giving it.
The answer is you shouldn't.
You shouldn't hire anybody to do anything
if you think you can do
it better for cheaper.
My obsession with building this,
DRock, get up a little bit,
let's get a little improv.
My obsession with building all of this
is predicated on one thing
which is that I think it's worth you
to pay us to do our thing
because I think I can do it better
than you could do it yourself
or some other agency down the street
can do it for the same price
or for more expensive.
The arbitrage of what they cost versus us,
that we're more valuable in return
and so the biggest
reasons most big companies
hire agencies is the
head count on their PNL
in corporate America,
in a Wall Street World
is looked upon as a
negative versus outsourcing
it to agencies.
The big reason that a medium
sized business should do it
is that they feel like
the investment is worth it
and the reason a small company
or individual should do it
is they've run out of time
but the fact of the matter is,
nobody should hire anybody,
digital agency or, I would hire somebody
to hang a picture in my house.
Let me tell you why.
One, I'm just not that handy.
Two, my time matters to me so much
and so I'd rather pay somebody
100 bucks to hang a picture
than to spend those four minutes
'cause I think I know what
to do with those four minutes
to make a 101 bucks, get it?
That's the game.
Can somebody do it better
that brings an ROI to you
and that's why agencies exist.
Can we, and don't forget this other thing,
if you bring it in-house,
you become a cocoon, right?
Like you're only working on your brand,
you're only seeing it
from your perspective
and you've lost all the other stuff.
By having so many people here,
I have so many different perspectives.
We have so much more data
across so many different brands
and then we use that for execution
across other brands, across myself.
This team here, what we're doing right now
is giving us a North Star of
execution for other clients.
I have better advice for
our clients around YouTube
and podcasting because the expectations,
not the expectations,
the execution, excuse me,
that was funny, I rarely
say the wrong word.
That was a very weird moment.
And so that, my friends,
is the reason to do it.
And that's the reason
for everything, right?
Like why am I, why are all these people,
show Andy.
He's not feeling very well.
(laughter)
Why's Andy here?
Because he can do it at an ROI
that's better than I can do it.
Do I have the time, this,
that, the other thing.
It goes on and on and on and on
and so that's the rationale,
Guy and VaynerNation.
Is it worth the investment
you put into it?
Just like everything
else you do in your life.
By the way, let's link up
the movie that Staphon edited
not DRock.
DRock, you got a lot
of credit for my return
to Wine Library video.
Pisses me off that you're
getting credit for that
so I wanna set the nation straight.
Let's link that right here.
As a matter fact, take over
the screen for a second
and pick your three favorite
seconds of it, Staphon.
(upbeat music)
Question of the day,
where do you watch or listen
to the #AskGaryVee Show?
Looking forward to this.
Lurkers, get your ass out.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
(makes shooting noises)
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks
in social so, subscribe!